[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
heute mit ihnen allen guten abend das
wichtigste an diesem donnerstag in den
nächsten 20 minuten sportliches gehört
dazu heute mit norbert lehmann scheint
doch von mir und hier sind unsere themen
wirtschaftsminister habeck ruf die
alarmstufe aus gas wird knapp in
deutschland und wohl noch teurer
historische entscheidung in brüssel
erwartet die eu berät ob die ukraine und
moldau beitrittskandidaten werden
mehr geld für studierende der bundestag
beschließt höhere bafög-sätze und
erweitert den kreis der berechtigten
wir sind in einer gaskrise sagt
wirtschaftsminister habeck und setzt als
reaktion auf die drastische verknappung
der liefermengen aus russland heute die
zweite stufe des notfallplans gas in
kraft es war nur eine frage der zeit und
von vielen schon erwartet worden seit
märz galt die frühe warnstufe einen
krisenstab nahm die arbeit auf versorger
und grossverbraucher sollten
selbstständig mehr gas beschaffen um die
speicher bestmöglich zu füllen jetzt
gilt eben die alarmstufe und sie erhöht
die dringlichkeit hat aber erst einmal
keine auswirkungen auf verbraucher
vorbereitet wird mehr kohlekraftwerke
einzusetzen und erdgas bei der
stromproduktion einzusparen und wer das
alles nichts nützt dann kann die
bundesregierung die notfall stufe
ausrufen dann entscheidet der staat über
die verteilung bevorzugt werden dann
etwa privathaushalte und soziale
einrichtungen wie krankenhäuser klaus
brodbeck es muss schneller gehen als
gedacht er geschehen als erhofft der
wirtschaftsminister im krisenmodus
wir haben in deutschland eine störung
der gasversorgung so ist definiert daher
ist es erforderlich
diese alarmstufe auszurufen
gas ist von nun an ein knappes gut in
deutschland der einbruch russische
gaslieferungen man den wichtigsten
übergabepunkten kommt seit 13 juni
dramatisch weniger an die auswirkungen
auf die preise auch dramatisch nur in
die andere richtung
energieversorger rufen bereits um hilfe
wir brauchen eine sehr schnelle
entscheidung auch des ministeriums wie
dann diese erhöhten preise auch zu
wälzen sind wie man mit diesen
überhöhten preis mit diesen erhöhten
preisen auch umgeht bedeutet auch
verbraucher müssen sich umstellen
wir rechnen damit dass in diesem jahr
alleine jetzt schon die haushalte mit
zusatzzahlungen im schnitt von 1000 bis
2000 euro rechnen müssen deutsche
gasspeicher sind derzeit zu 58 prozent
gefüllt zu wenig für den winter müsste
gar die notfall stufe ausgerufen werden
wäre dies ein schock beklagt die
opposition
der schock wäre aber geringer wenn es
vorher einen plan gibt einen plan den
wir seit wochen
einfordern hier im deutschen bundestag
bitte bereiten sie auch das vor was noch
kommen kann mitmachen das maximale tempo
damit dass in diesem land gelingt herr
spahn ich weiß nicht ob es ihnen
aufgefallen ist aber das ist teil
unseres plans um dieses land aus der
krise zu führen im gasbereich in die sie
dieses land geführt habe das ist daher
ist bahn für industrie wie verbraucher
wie viel energie im winter fehlt derzeit
ziemlich offen
wir gehen zur börse nach frankfurt zu
frank bethmann frank viele machen sich
jetzt große sorgen bedeutet die
alarmstufe dass es auf jeden fall noch
teurer wird für die verbraucher na ja
sehr viel teurer wird es in jedem fall
aber ab wann mit der alarmstufe wird
jetzt geklärt wann die energieversorger
ihre höheren einkaufspreise weitergeben
können erst mit der jahresendabrechnung
oder doch schon durch sofort deutlich
höhere abschlagszahlungen eine erst
kürzlich vorgenommene änderung am
energie sicherungs gesetz schützt die
verbraucher vorerst noch den sofortige
preiserhöhung wurden an weitere
bedingungen geknüpft die
bundesnetzagentur muss dafür zusätzlich
zur alarmstufe förmlich eine erhebliche
reduzierung der gesamt gasimport man
feststellen noch hat sie das nicht getan
noch dürfen die energieversorger also
ihre gestiegenen einkaufspreise nicht an
ihre kunden weitergeben das würde sich
aber sofort ändern sollte die
bundesnetzagentur nicht bei ihrer
meinung bleiben käme deutlich zu wenig
gas nach deutschland könnten die
preissteigerungen unmittelbar
weitergegeben werden in amsterdam steigt
derweil der europäische referenzpreis
für gas wieder an wir haben es gerade
gesehen um über 4% was nahe liegt dass
sich verbraucher und industrie auf
weitere preiserhöhungen gefasst machen
müssen frank bethmann vielen dank nach
frankfurt
27 mal ja zur ukraine als eu
beitrittskandidaten auch für die
republik malt auch dafür hat sich
kanzler stolz auf dem heutigen eu gipfel
stark gemacht und vieles deutet darauf
hin dass es klappt aber was ist mit den
sechs teilweise schon sehr lange warten
den westbalkanstaaten die sind zum einen
teilweise untereinander zerstritten zum
anderen aber auch frustriert über das
tempo mit dem die ukraine den status zu
erlangen scheint die beratungen mit der
eu über den westbalkan wurden heute
ergebnislos beendet ina don't
herzlich begrüßt sich die gipfelrunde
denn es wird bei all gegen krisen etwas
zu feiern geben die ukraine soll zum
beitrittskandidaten ernannt werden und
weil das vor allem ein signal der
solidarität ist dann eigentlich niemand
mehr etwas dagegen haben das ist wichtig
dass wir in europa eigentlich handeln
deshalb habe ich in den letzten tagen
und wochen mit vielen sehr intensiv
gesprochen gespielt hingegen ist die
idylle auf dem familienfoto mit den
sechs fest balkanländern sie haben
heftig mit der europäischen union
gestritten jeder einzelne schritt auf
dem weg zur eu-mitgliedschaft muss von
allen 27 eu ländern einstimmig
gutgeheissen werden doch immer wieder
findet sich mindestens ein land dass er
ein veto einlegt darum laufen die
verhandlungen mit serbien seit gut acht
jahren die mit montenegro seit zehn
jahren eine gefühlte ewigkeit warten
albanien und nord mazedonien auf den
beginn ihrer gespräche beide werden in
einem paket behandelt doch die aufnahme
von gesprächen mit nord mazedonien wird
von bulgarien blockiert dabei arbeiten
doch alle längst in der nato zu sammeln
bulgarien nimmt zwei andere nato länder
albanien und mazedonien inmitten eines
heißen krieges in europa in geiselhaft
die anderen 26 eu-staaten haben eine
furchterregende
inkompetenz gezeigt
auf den kandidatenstatus warten bosnien
herzegowina und das kosovo das sich
zunächst schon mit einer visa freiheit
bedeutet
wir haben alle auflagen erfüllt und es
ist jetzt an der zeit dass die
mitgliedsländer dem prozess unterstützen
es ist eine große ungerechtigkeit
gegenüber den menschen im kosovo
vorwürfe und keine fortschritte für die
west balkan länder aber die ukraine und
auch die republik moldau werden wohl den
kandidatenstatus bekommen den sie sich
so sehr erhofft
mir geht's so anne gellinek nach brüssel
also in sachen beitritt status ganz
schwere geburt in brüssel ein nein zum
westbalkan und vermutlich ein ja zur
ukraine was ist das für ein signal
man sieht an der debatte um die
erweiterung die zwei gesichter der
europäischen union im fall der ukraine
ist die union angesichts einer großen
krise eines kriegs in der lage eine zwar
symbolische entscheidung aber doch eine
wichtige politische weichenstellung zu
treffen und der ukraine wenn es denn so
kommt den kandidatenstatus zu verleihen
im fall westbalkan ist die krise nur
scheinbar geringer und schon greifen
alle mechanismen die die europäische
union langsam und schwerfällig machen
mal blockiert das einem mitgliedsland
die einstimmigkeit bremst und es fehlt
führung um den knoten zu durchschlagen
die 27 staats und regierungschefs der
europäischen union wollen heute ihre
entscheidung der ukraine den
kandidatenstatus zu verleihen historisch
nennen dann muss man aber wohl auch
sagen dass das belassen des westbalkans
im warteraum der eu ein historischer
fehler wäre dankeschön nach brüssel anne
gellinek zwar hat die ukraine für ihren
abwehrkampf nach der deutschen lieferung
auch schwere waffen von den usa erhalten
aber möglicherweise zu spät um den
vormarsch russischer truppen im osten zu
stoppen laut ukrainischen generalstab
bezeichnet der gegner geländegewinne
mehr jetzt von antoine kurschilgen
russische raketenwerfer feuern ob
klinische stellungen in der region
luhansk at russische armee offenbar drei
weitere orte erobert darunter das
strategisch wichtige dorf kam auch die
anderen eroberten orte liegen in der
nähe von lisicki noch ist die stadt
unter ukrainischer kontrolle doch die
russische armee ist offenbar kurz davor
lizenz einzukesseln die ukrainischen
truppen wären dann wohl dort vom
nachschub abgeschnitten
vor dem krieg lebten hier hunderttausend
menschen die meisten sind geflohen rund
7000 harren noch aus freiwillige helfen
sie in sicherheit zu bringen denn die
zeit drängt
street hier wird es bald straßenkämpfe
geben vielleicht monate lang diese
menschen müssen weg hier viele werden
sterben oder unter schrecklichsten
umständen leben
schwere angriffe auch in der hafenstadt
nikolajew im süden der ukraine
hier wurde unter anderem eine
produktionsstätte für pflanzenöl
bombardiert moskau veröffentlichte heute
auch diese bilder nachschub für die
front per zug die botschaft die
offensive im osten der ukraine geht
voran
das oberste gericht der usa stuft das
tragen von waffen in der öffentlichkeit
als grundrecht 1 damit kippt der supreme
court ein gesetz im bundesstaat new york
es hatte verlangt dass menschen einen
besonderen bedarf nachweisen müssen um
eine waffe mit sich zu führen die
einflussreiche waffenlobby nhl feierte
die entscheidung als sieg us-präsident
beiden reagierte tief enttäuscht
zum verheerenden erdbeben in afghanistan
ein land das ohnehin leidet auch unter
dürre und hunger laut welthungerhilfe
wissen 20 millionen afghanen nicht wie
sie sich ernähren sollen die lage nach
dem beben ist schwierig bleibt
unübersichtlich diverse
hilfsorganisationen auch deutsche sind
auf dem weg ins schwer zugängliche
katastrophengebiet die uno spricht
inzwischen von 770 toten die zahl könnte
noch stark steigen jörg brase berichtet
die helfer und auch unser kamerateam
quälen sich über schlammige überflutete
straßen hinauf in die berge in die
zerstörten dörfer diese bilder machen
klar wie schwierig es ist hilfe in die
entlegenen regionen zu bringen vor ort
bietet sich ein bild der zerstörung die
überlebenden stehen immer noch unter
schock
das dort war unser haus und daneben das
war eine religionsschule für mädchen da
sind nur ein kind und ein erwachsener
lebend rausgekommen alle anderen wurden
getötet
sie tragen ihre toten zu grabe viele
frauen und kinder sind darunter unter
tränen nehmen sie abschied von ihren
angehörigen fast jede familie hat opfer
zu beklagen
in meinem eigenen haus statt glücklicher
weise niemand aber in der familie meines
bruders staaten 36 und sie standen mir
sehr nach
im provinzkrankenhaus von praktiker
liegen viele der verletzten das örtliche
gesundheitssystem ist überlastet
wenn wir patienten in andere
krankenhäuser verlegen wollen haben wir
das problem dass es zu wenig
krankenwagen gibt ständig haben wir mit
solchen schwierigkeiten zu kämpfen
sie verschaffen ihre angehörigen in
massengräbern und warten auf hilfe um
über die kalten nächte zu kommen um ihre
häuser wieder aufzubauen doch sie werden
warten müssen vielleicht noch sehr lange
bis irgendwann die hilfe auch zu ihnen
hier oben in den bergen kommt
wenn sie den menschen in afghanistan
helfen wollen das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe hat ein spendenkonto
eingerichtet mit der u bahn de 65 104
106 100 104 106 100 stichwort zdf
nothilfe afghanistan noch einmal
nachzulesen alles unter spenden zdf.de
und auf der zdf textseite
im bevölkerungsreichsten bundesland
nordrhein westfalen wird es wohl
erstmals eine schwarz grüne regierung
geben cdu und grüne einigten sich auf
einen koalitionsvertrag
ministerpräsident wüst sagte beide
parteien hätten mit mehr klimaschutz
sowie investitionen in bildung und
infrastruktur einen gemeinsamen kompass
die grünen-landeschefin neubauer betonte
man wolle nrw zur ersten klimaneutralen
industrieregion europas machen am
wochenende müssen noch die parteitage zu
stellen
schüler auszubildende und studenten
bekommen ab dem wintersemester mehr
bafög der bundestag stimmte einer
erhöhung der staatlichen
ausbildungsförderung zu in zukunft
sollen auch wieder mehr junge menschen
bafög berechtigt werden denn die zahl
der bafög-empfänger die geht seit jahren
zurück waren es 2012 noch knapp 980 1000
schüler und studenten bezogen die
leistung 2020 nur noch knapp 640.000
also ein minus von 35 prozent und jetzt
der versuch den trend umzukehren andreas
linke
hanna gutknecht studierte in stuttgart
an der hochschule der medien engagiert
sich bei der grünen jugend noch lebt sie
bei ihren eltern wohnen in stuttgart ist
teuer
wie viel würde ich dann merken wenn ich
ausziehen würde das reichen und bei mit
studierenden ist das geld noch knapper
ich muss besonders sparen ich kann kaum
raus ich kann bist du jeden tag
die bundesregierung will etwas abhilfe
schaffen die ministerin sagte im
bundestag sie wolle die wahl für den
eigenen selbstständigen bildungsweg
erleichtern die bisherige förderung hat
noch zu viele ausgeschlossen wir kehren
diesen trend um mehr bafög heißt mehr
freiheit das sind die inhalte der
bafög-novelle studierende können künftig
statt 8 161 bis zu 9 134 euro erhalten
mit darlehensanteil die grenze ab der
das einkommen der eltern angerechnet
wird steigt von 2000 auf 2.415 euro
studierenden organisationen fordern eine
noch weitergehende anpassung an das
wahre leben zum beispiel bei der voerder
höchstdauer regelstudienzeit plus zwei
semester für die meisten studieren außer
dem studienfach wechseln müssen einfach
ermöglicht werden das budget muss eltern
unabhängig werden und das war muss
wieder dahin zurück wo es war nämlich zu
einem vollzuschuss damit auch die angst
vor verschuldung wegfällt so dass auch
studentinnen wie anna gutknecht ein
bisschen entspannt erleben und an ihre
zukunft arbeiten können
wieder streik in deutschlands großen
seehäfen diesmal für 24 stunden so zogen
in hamburg tausende durch die stadt sie
fordern ein euro 20 mehr stundenlohn und
eine erhöhung jährlicher zulagen in
bestimmten betrieben eine vierte
verhandlungsrunde mit arbeitgebern war
vorher gescheitert der steig jetzt
dürfte die ohnehin verspätete
abfertigung von waren weiter verzögern
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach hat
vor einer neuen schweren corona welle im
herbst gewarnt gemeinsam mit seinen
länder kollegen will er deswegen in
einer woche maßnahmen für diese zeit
vorstellen das lka registrierte
119.000 360 neue infektionen innerhalb
eines tages 30 1218 mehr als vor einer
woche die dunkelziffer liegt vermutlich
sehr viel höher 98 menschen starben
binnen 24 stunden im zusammenhang mit
dem virus die sieben tage incidents
liegt jetzt erstmals seit mitte mai bei
über 500
wir machen mit dem sport weiter heute
haben in berlin die final zu kommen
117 14 sportarten alles in einer stadt
an vier tagen ein ganz besonderes multi
sport event und den ersten deutschen
meistertitel der gab es heute erstmals
in einer ganz neuen sportart im speed
kanupolo
vier gegen vier mitten auf der spree an
der east side gallery der b liga verein
ksv havel brüder gewinnt das finale im
neuen speed format gegen rothemühle
essen mit 7 zu 3 der schnelle und
schwangere sport hat einen ersten
deutschen meister einmal durch die mitte
in den prenzlauer berg 7 km weiter
nördlich in der max schmeling halle
hatte auch leonie adam einen höhenflug
die neue deutsche meisterin im trampolin
zeigte bei schrauben und soll die die
beste ausführung
die 29 jährige gewinnt ihren fünften
titel
schlussläuferin lena meißner sichert der
treppe und mixed staffel aus buschhütten
den deutschen meistertitel im
olympiastadion verteidigt das team
seinen erfolg über die sprintdistanz vor
potsdam und berlin
jan morgen sind die finales bei uns im
zdf live zu sehen ab 13 uhr beim
wta-tennisturnier in bad homburg sind
die beiden letzten deutschen
spielerinnen an zwei französischen
gescheitert zunächst verlor sabine
lisicki im viertelfinale gegen caroline
garcia danach musste sich an schlägt
herber gegen alizé cornet geschlagen
geben
martin hinteregger beendet überraschend
seine karriere als fußball-profi der 29
jährige abwehrspieler von eintracht
frankfurt zieht damit die konsequenzen
aus seinen geschäftsbeziehungen zu einem
rechtspopulistische politiker ein paar
wochen nach dem frankfurter europa
league sie kommt das aus für den
langjährigen österreichischen
nationalspieler frage 1 von ihm geplant
das hobby toni entkernten und die damit
verbundenen kürzlich aufgedeckten
kontakte zum rechtspopulistischen fpö
politiker heinrich sickl liefert den
hintergrund für den abschied hinteregger
distanzierte sich von rechtem intolerant
im gedankengut in der mitteilung seines
rücktritts auf der internetseite des
vereins seien noch zwei jahre gültigen
vertrag bei der eintracht wird aufgelöst
er war ein echter kult spieler bekommen
der überrannt vielen dank norbert heute
nacht und morgen drohen gewitter wie
heftig und wer wo verschont bleibt
gleich von katja horneffer
wirtschaftsminister habeck im
heute-journal interview bei marietta
slomka ab 21 uhr 45 schönen dank schönen
abend und am besten schön dran bleiben
bei uns hier im zdf bis mo
[Musik]
guten abend schon heute vormittag gab es
die ersten heftigen gewitter hier über
südfrankreich hat sich ein gewittertief
formiert und das bringt die gewitter
jetzt auch zu uns nach deutschland
in der nacht ziehen die über baden
württemberg weiter in richtung bayern
aber auch westlich von uns in
rheinland-pfalz im saarland auch in
nordrhein westfalen und dem westlich
niedersachsen sollten sie sich heute
nacht auf kräftige gewitter einstellen
mit hagel platzregen und sturmböen hier
im nordosten bekommen sie davon nichts
mit da bleibt die nacht klar und die
temperaturen sinken auf 15 bis 13 grad
in dieser schweren gewitter luft bleibt
es deutlich wärmer mit 9 10 bis 15 grad
und morgen ist es weiterhin dampf sich
21 bis 26 grad sind es zumeist im
nordosten klettern die werte auf 28 bis
33 grad und zwischen dem erzgebirge und
der ostseeküste scheint häufig die sonne
sonst entwickeln sich kräftige schauer
und gewitter besonders am nachmittag
diese unwetter sind wir dann am samstag
los dann gewitters vielleicht noch im
nordosten es beruhigt sich vorübergehend
das wetter bei 23 bis 29 grad aber schon
am sonntag kommen dann von westen neue
schauer und gewitter auf und es wird im
osten wieder richtig heiß gute nacht